stevie
est-ce très possible, je veux dire vraiment ne pas
être drôle,
mais un homme blanc peut-il être funky
bien, je peux voir l'unité blanche, mais euh,
cependant, tout le monde peut être funky
dans la mesure où cela dépend de la
capacité des gens à accepter
les sociétés
et les cultures de l'autre  à peu près la même chose que
michael jackson
tu étais aussi un enfant star tu penses
que ça l'a changé plus que ça
t'a changé
euh j'aurais un record de succès peut-être tous
les deux ans
en 1963 j'avais le bout des doigts en 1965
j'étais tendu
en 1967  j'avais on m'a fait l'aimer
et puis 1968 j'ai eu des points dans ma vie
1969 à
masharimul et puis c'est en 1962 à
partir de 72 que j'ai eu la superstition
euh je ne sais pas je veux dire le point est que
michael a commencé quand il avait environ cinq ans
ou six ans
euh et le genre de
succès qu'il a eu euh
tu sais quand tu es le plus grand artiste
de l'histoire américaine
en ce qui concerne les ventes de disques je veux dire que quelque
chose doit te faire quelque chose
je pense aussi avec les diverses choses
que les gens  a dit  à propos de
euh sa vie sa vie personnelle c'est vraiment
l'affaire de personne
ce n'est pas mon affaire c'est connaître vos
affaires
ce n'est pas l'affaire de personne l'
essentiel est
qu'il nous a donné de la très très bonne
musique il a été avec un grand producteur
quincy jones
il vient d'un  famille très talentueuse
et
tout ce que nous pouvons faire, c'est espérer que nous pourrons avoir
aussi longtemps qu'il est en vie
pour nous donner cette bonne musique et cette
excitation
maintenant combien tu vas me payer pour avoir
dit que michael
stevie pourriez-vous s'il vous plaît nous dire du
jour que  tu es allé à la motown
et tu as rencontré mr barry golly jr
le jour où je suis allé à la motown
était très très excitant c'était presque
comme être
dans un vrai magasin de musique où il y
avait beaucoup d'instruments
à jouer ce n'était pas comme être  dans un
studio
et en repensant à ce jour-là,
je ne savais pas que
j'auditionnais pour mon travail, je n'y avais jamais
pensé comme ça, mais en réalité, je suppose que
j'étais euh mais barry gordy n'était pas là
les suprêmes n'étaient pas là  mais d  iane
était là l'
un des membres du groupe était
ancien était alors plus tard appelé les
tentations
paul williams était là certains des enfants de very
goody étaient là
et euh mary wells était là
je l'ai rencontrée elle venait de gagner un concours de talents
de son école  et euh, elle m'en a parlé
et barry gordy est venu un peu plus tard,
il est supposé que quand je suis entré pour la première fois,
il était à la maison en train de manger un steak
et quelqu'un l'a appelé et lui a dit que tu devais
venir voir ce petit garçon
jouant de tous ces instruments en chantant
tous ces  chansons dont je me souviens avoir dit à
smokey robinson qui était là aussi j'ai
dit que
je peux voir mieux que toi je peux te voir de
toute façon c'était une journée excitante
est-il vrai que barry gordy était très
dur
et que les règles de la chronologie motown
étaient très très très dures
barry  gordy était
alors président de la motown le propriétaire de la
motown
euh très très précis sur ce qu'il
voulait
très très sûr et il croyait
très fermement au son de la motown les
musiciens
les différents artistes les auteurs-compositeurs  et
ce n'était pas tant que les lois de la Motown
étaient dures ou dures, je veux dire en gros
euh ce qui se passe maintenant avec les
maisons de disques qui ont des attentes à propos
de certains disques
qu'ils sortent par certains artistes, ils
n'accepteront tout simplement pas le disque à moins que ce ne soit comme
ça
à l'époque, beaucoup de chansons ont été coupées,
beaucoup de chansons ont été rejetées ainsi que
celles qui
ont été acceptées et euh
l'autre chose est que beaucoup d'
artistes étaient mineurs, ils n'avaient pas 21 ans
ou
ils approchaient juste de 21
juste avoir 21 ans alors là  il y avait certaines
règles
et réglementations comme par exemple qu'il
était interdit de boire dans les
bus,
évidemment pas de fumer un pot dans les bus,
les artistes qui étaient jeunes
devaient absolument se coucher à une certaine heure
et tous ceux qui avaient plus de 13 ans étaient mes
parents
donc cela signifiait que les merveilles qui
étaient comme 14 15 16 et 17
pensaient toutes qu'elles étaient mes parents ou mes
grandes sœurs ou quoi que
martha reeves tous et c'était
bien parce
que comme vous le savez, cela a fait ressortir
des artistes très talentueux
stevie comment avez-vous réussi à enregistrer à
la alors qu'un autre
groupe de musiciens et de chanteurs se produisait
à new york en même temps
il y avait une expérience faite euh
avec les
bell labs un studio à new york
mon studio au pays des merveilles à los angeles
et sprint où ils ont utilisé la
fibre optique, ils ont utilisé
une connexion par satellite
et ils ont utilisé une chanson particulière que
j'avais
écrite j'étais moi-même maintenant rogers et
quincy jones
euh quelques élèves du
lycée de new
york quelques enfants appellent stop don '  t pass go
et c'était une chanson anti-crack
et c'était pour voir si en fait l'enregistrement
pouvait être fait
euh d'un océan à l'autre euh à travers la fibre
optique et le
numérique cela a fonctionné avec
succès si bien que euh
nous parlons maintenant à certaines personnes dans
le japon à
propos de la construction du pays des merveilles tokyo
si vous imaginez que nous sommes maintenant en 1993
et que vous venez d'être élu maire de la
ville de détroit michi
an que ferez-vous monsieur le maire pour faire de détr
it une meilleure ville en tant
ue maire de  la ville de détroit je
veux tout d'abord exiger que tous les
enfants aveugles sortent de la rue
du côté sérieux je crois que euh
les choses que je devrai donner à
la ville
et pour la ville feront
finalement de détroit le modèle  ville à laquelle
toutes les villes du monde
voudront ressembler en toute sincérité
dors-tu jamais pourquoi pas oui je le
fais mais est-ce que tu
oui je le fais mais quand je dors tu sais ce qui
se passe quand je dors
bleu